RACHEL BEEN: Hi, I'm Rachel.
VIKTOR PERSSON: I'm Viktor.
HANNAH CHO: Hi, I'm Hannah.
CHRISTIAN ROBERTSON:
And I'm Christian.
And we're designers that have
been working on this material
design project, helping our
various products at Google
to bring the material
designed to it.
So yesterday in our keynote,
we introduced this concept
of material design.
And it's a system that
uses the classical tools
of print-like
graphic design, along
with some new
dynamic surfaces that
appeal to our innate
understanding of physics
and material.
Today we're going to talk about
how some of the visual design
concepts help to
define that system.
So, it's not often
recognized about design
that a good portion of it
happens behind the scenes.
People don't actually
recognize-- or notice
actively-- a lot of the choices
that we make as designers.
Sometimes even people
thinking about visual design
think of it as a
skinny, or covering,
that's kind of happened
at the very last moment.
And today we want to show
that beauty isn't skin deep.
We're going to challenge
the idea of visual design
as a skin.
We want to talk about
the visible and invisible
structures that make
the material UI work.
So, we'll show how
invisible grids
can hold the structure together.
We'll talk about the rules
behind the scenes that
can help us have better imagery,
and we'll pull the camera back
to show the lighting
and the shadow systems.
So, I'll start with one of the
more invisible, yet visible
everywhere, design
practices-- typography.
Typography's a lot more than
just the choice of typeface,
but the letter forms are
a good place to start.
So, I'll start
talking about Roboto.
Roboto's a custom
typeface that's
designed with UI
specifically in mind.
It's a digital native.
And we're using a
new cut of Roboto
as a default typeface
for the material UI.
We've extensively
reworked the outlines
to make sure that the
types work, not just
on mobile and tablet, where
we've started using it,
but across the
various form factors
that we're now covering.
So, here's some of the changes.
This way you'll be able to
pick out the new version
from the old version and impress
your type-obsessed friends.
So, we've calmed down some of
the more unruly characters.
We also rounded out the
squarer sides on the caps,
as well as the dots
and the punctuation.
We also completely
redrew the numbers.
And, getting into the details,
we reworked all of the italics
so that we have better
optical correction
to the diagonal strokes.
So, if you look at the right
leg of the A versus the left leg
of the A, you might notice
a very slight difference.
So, really we treat
almost every single glyph
to polish and tune.
There's a lot of changes in
the spacing and the metrics.
I'll spare you the
rest of the details.
But the typeface itself really
is only a part of typography.
In fact, if you call a type
designer a typographer,
he'll point out the
difference between the two.
Typography is the use of type.
One of our design principles
was to enable content that's
bold and graphic
and intentional.
And this graphic character
starts with the typography.
In fact, when you actually
look at UI's, it's
clear that on
almost every screen,
type is the primary element.
So, if I block out just
the type on the right,
you can see how
the screen really
is structured by the typography.
In fact, this is
a good exercise--
as you're designing things,
just block it out and just
look at the type itself, and
see if it contains a structure.
UI design really is typography.
If we're drawing screens,
whether we know it or not,
we're typographers.
So, this design system
uses really big type
to be expressive,
but also to create
clear hierarchies
of information.
It's tempting when we're
doing UI design to--
just because we're
always dealing
with dynamic content--
it's tempting to just
use the smallest size
possible, because we don't know
in a music player if the band
name is going to be super long,
or we don't know
if in a calculator
that we're going to have a
calculation that's super long.
Instead, we can use large
type and then adjust the size
to accommodate the
copy as needed.
So, it's these
large display sizes
that are also another
opportunity for branding, where
you might consider
using a custom type,
commissioning a new type,
or even licensing a type.
It's easier than it might seem.
So, to help us
manage the sizes, we
use a tool called the
typographic scale.
This isn't a new idea.
This has been around in
print for a long time.
In fact, the classic
typographic scale
uses the same math as the
musical pentatonic scale.
It makes sure that there's
enough contrast at each step.
And what it really
does is it reduces
the amount of distinct
sizes on any one screen,
so that information
is clear, and you
can tell those differences.
A good rule of thumb is if
you're using more than two
or three sizes on
one screen, you
should make sure that
there's a good reason for it.
And if you are
using a size that's
not in the typographic
scale, there
should be a really
good reason for it.
Ultimately, though,
the purpose of type
is to serve the content.
It's to help people quickly
parse and communicate
the information.
And while typography uses up
a good portion of our screen
real estate in many ways,
it's hard to beat imagery--
photographs and
illustrations-- for impact.
RACHEL BEEN: So, this
epitomizing phrase
that we've been hearing
a lot of content
being bold, graphic,
and intentional
is especially apparent with
the use of imagery in product.
So, we aren't here to encourage
specific aesthetic identities.
Product brands range from
being subdued and muted
to really bright and colorful.
And our intention isn't
to prescribe brand.
What we want to encourage
is intentionality and
thoughtfulness concerning
imagery, backed
by supported principles and best
practices, to make your imagery
and your products come to life
and feel really differentiated.
So, we define the
main principles
of imagery in a
three-part statement--
be personal, be informative,
and be delightful.
So personalize
the imagery, where
applicable, to make your
product feel relevant.
A degree of intelligence
is automatically
communicated if imagery
accurately reflects the user.
Inform the user with a visual
translation of information.
This facilitates
comprehension, and allows
for expedited understanding
of information.
And delight.
Delight doesn't mean adding
superfluous, fluffy imagery
just to fill space.
Delight really implies
aesthetic thoughtfulness,
combined with appropriate
contextual use.
Delight can make your product
feel not only special,
but really considerate
of the user.
So, some additional
principles to talk through.
Imagery doesn't have
to be consistently
conspicuous to feel appropriate.
So, this concept of
being immersive, right?
The image above
is a great example
of using imagery to create
context and interest
without overpowering
the primary information.
The artist portrait is
a textual background
for the interactive
music content,
which is the primary focus.
Use appropriate imagery
hinting at contextualization
to create this type of depth
and texture in your product.
So, be thoughtfully ubiquitous.
So ubiquitous imagery,
similar to delight,
doesn't imply superfluous
use without a rationale.
Ubiquity here implies
searching for very intentional
visual opportunities,
where previously there
might have been disparities.
So, look for these moments
to introduce imagery
that supports information
personalization and delight.
So, context.
User should feel that, in every
instance, imagery is visible.
It feels relevant
and appropriate,
and not disorienting or
misleading or out of place.
So, this doesn't always
mean that imagery
has to be a literal translation
of surrounding information,
right?
So, the example
above is perfect.
We don't see the literal facade
of the location of your event,
rather, a feature image from the
location that provides context.
But context in the
type of context,
such as cuisine, and the
general aesthetic and vibe,
and potentially even
the time of day.
So, this contextual accuracy,
combined with really beautiful
imagery, will create the
best possible experience
for your users.
So, best practices.
I want to touch really lightly
on some overarching practices
when creating or
commissioning imagery.
From an aesthetic
perspective, the main goal
is to create beautiful
images, right?
Your users will feel
inspired and excited to use
your product.
But beautiful imagery is a
somewhat broad and amorphous
term, so here's some
overarching tips basically
to point you in the
right direction.
Ensure that a clear concept
is conveyed in a memorable way
with having a point of focus.
This doesn't
necessarily literally
translate as a single point
of focus in your image.
Focus more so
conveys that there's
clear representation that
won't be lost on the user.
The user should be able to
parse almost immediately what
the visual represents.
Building narratives take
this concept of focus
and adds some flavor, right?
Is the mood of the image
aspirational, somber,
celebratory?
So, this example of Miami is
not only visually informative--
in terms of the location
that the user's travelling
to-- but it's meant to also be
an aspirational and immersive
image, creating really
positive connotations with
your location.
So, all imagery is an
editorialized decision, right?
So make intentional
decisions about the narrative
of your product through imagery.
I want to end up this section
about imagery speaking
about some UI
integration, and how
imagery lives within the
material design structure.
So, scale.
Not all assets hold
the same visual weight.
An avatar in an account
switcher is purposely
smaller than a main hero
image, because of information
hierarchy, right?
So, be mindful of these
scale differentiations
between imagery types such,
as avatars, feature images,
et cetera, as well a
similar asset types,
such as thumbnails within
a gallery experience.
Scale in a hierarchy
imply importance,
and not all of your
assets are equal.
OK, So this seems
obvious, but make sure
your images are appropriately
sized for their containers
and across platforms.
Material designed
really emphasizes
large containers, large
real estate, and ideally
these assets should
not appear pixelated
in your container's
cross-platform.
So also, as you can see
in many of the vignettes,
a lot of the UI color choices
reflect content, right?
So, this was spoken
about the keynote.
So, color and imagery
and material design
are really symbiotic.
These bold color
bars, action bars,
should look to a really
intentional color sampling
story.
This not only creates a
perceived intelligence
concerning the content, but will
make your product feel unique.
We're building a support library
called Palette, which was also
mentioned in the keynote, which
is part of the Android support
library and will be part
of the L Preview release.
You will be able to use
it pretty much right away.
So, what the library
does is automatically
extract a color palette
based on a particular image.
We're still iterating
on the algorithms
and the API's, so
expect improvements
on this in the future.
And Viktor is
going to speak more
about color in a little bit.
So, before I end, I want to
talk about different image types
within the container, so you can
start naming these asset types
and thinking about
how to use these.
So, avatars and thumbnails.
Avatars are representations of
entities-- brands and people--
and most commonly
displayed in circular form.
Thumbnails allow
the user to peek
into additional visual
content, usually surrounded
by heterogeneous information,
such as copy, titles, et
cetera.
They're always actionable
into a more immersive view.
And I think this is the primary
point of what a thumbnail is.
They're always thinking at more.
So, thumbnails are great assets
to introduce and really tighten
constrained spaces.
In material design, we're
introducing two types
of hero images-- featured
heroes and integrated heroes.
A feature hero is really
a bold, primary point
of focus, surrounded by
a heterogeneous layout
with additional information.
But the user's eye
should really look first
to this visual while
still interacting
with the surrounding content.
Integrated heroes
create a setting
for heterogeneous pieces
of content within a layout.
They're not the primary
points of focus,
but more add texture
and depth to the scene.
Gallery images.
Well, gallery images are the
most bold visual hero images
within your layouts.
Usually they're
homogeneous layouts,
and these are visual
heroes without
any other visual distractions.
These are the strongest and most
unobstructed views of imagery
within your product.
So overall, imagery is a
vital part of material design.
Thoughtfully incorporating
informative, personal,
delightful imagery
in your product,
while considering some
of these best practices,
is really going to bring
your product to life,
creating really memorable
and beautifully crafted
experiences for your user.
So as I mentioned
before, imagery is really
united with color,
so Viktor's going
to come up and speak
more about that.
VIKTOR PERSSON: Let's
talk about color
and how to use color to enhance
your branding and your user
experience.
The material design system
enables bold and intentional
use of color, and I
figured the best way
to show you this is to
design an example app.
When choosing your
color theme, you
should really use
your brand colors.
If you happen not to
have brand colors,
we've actually created an
extensive color palette
with beautiful colors
that we use ourselves
to define our own color themes.
This example app's primary
color will be indigo blue.
This is the main
color of the app.
So, if your brand color
is red, for example,
this color should really be red.
Bold and immersive use of
color is strongly encouraged.
With that said, not all
screens are the same.
Density of color depends
on the density of content.
So, in a screen with
very little content,
it enables bolder use of
color than, let's say,
a content-heavy list view.
Here are a few good
examples of how
bold color is applied
in more generous ways.
It brings to life otherwise
utilitarian experiences,
such as the
calculator, or how it
can complement
immersive imagery.
OK, let's move on and choose
the accent color for this app.
This color is to
provide contrast
for important buttons, UI
elements, and components.
Don't choose an
accent color that
doesn't provide enough contrast.
This color is really
supposed to pop.
Here are a few good examples of
how an accent color can provide
the right focus and attention
to certain areas or components.
If you've chosen an
accent color that
doesn't work in certain
circumstances, don't worry.
You can always fall back
to a lighter or darker tint
of that same color.
Pull those colors
together, and you'll
get your basic color theme.
We are very happy that we've
baked this into the Android
platform and made it
a lot easier for you
guys to define your
own color theme.
And remember, the
strongest tool we
have to unite a user experience
across multiple platforms
and devices is color.
So, we talked about
the design principles.
We talked about typography.
We talked about
imagery and color.
Let's bring them all
together and design
a beautiful and consistent UI.
As Zach mentioned earlier
in the direction talk,
over the course
of design history,
there have emerged
rules and guidelines
that we as designers are really,
really excited about that we
baked this in and included in
the material design system.
So here a few examples of
these rules and guidelines.
So, structural elements
in the material
designed system
aligns to an 8dp grid.
This will provide consistency,
harmony, and rhythm
to your designs.
Content should follow
a set of key lines.
16dp and 72dp on
mobile, 24dp and 80dp
on tablets, desktops,
and larger screen sizes.
As you can see here, it
really orders the content
and structures the
content so that it becomes
more predictable, and your
user can read this content
a lot easier and faster.
Increments is an
excellent tool, or help,
to determine the size of
larger structural elements,
such as the app bar
or the nav drawer.
The increments are based on the
standard app bar height, which
is 56dp on mobile and
64dp on tablets, desktops,
and larger screen sizes.
When setting your type,
make sure to align it
to a 4dp baseline grid.
This will make your
typography and content easier
to read and make it
aesthetically more pleasing.
I'm sure everyone
here at some point
has seen a design or
an app and just felt
like, oh, there's something off.
Not aligning your type to
a consistent baseline grid
might very well have been
what was the problem there.
Let's go back to our example
app again and apply these rules
and guides that we've
incorporated in the material
design system.
This is going to be a fairly
straightforward list view app,
but I wanted to enable
bolder use of color,
as I talked about before.
So, I made the app bar
3x of the increment.
When designing your layouts,
start thinking in blocks.
This is extremely helpful, and
will make your design process
easier, faster, and,
I would say, better.
For this app, I'm going to
use an avatar to the left,
with two lines of
text next to it.
So for that I'll
use a block of 72dp.
When placing in your content,
as I said, follow the key lines.
In this example, the
16dp and 24dp key line
is reserved for
icons and avatars.
That means that your
typography and text
should follow the 72dp
and 82dp key line.
As you can clearly see,
it provides a structure
and a predictability
to the eye that
is just very user-friendly
and easy to scan.
Last but not least,
remember the baseline grid.
Align your typography
to the baseline
grid to achieve
better typography.
And there we have it.
By using these-- I would
say almost magical tools
and guidelines, as well
as fundamental tools
and guidelines, we've created a
bold, beautiful, user-friendly
UI over multiple platforms
and form factors.
Over to Hannah, who
is going to talk
about surface and dimension.
HANNAH CHO: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HANNAH CHO: Yay.
OK, so Viktor just went
over on the details
of how to create a layout.
In material design, you
have to also consider
how these elements live and
move in 3D space, not just 2D.
We can model how people perceive
material in our UI to group
and structure our content.
The use of surface and material
can solve spatial issues,
and they're not meant to
be used just as decoration.
So, in material design,
we use this technique
to give our UI dimension.
So, we interact with
physical objects every day.
The tangible
qualities and shadows
help us to quickly
understand affordances.
So, we were inspired by the
tactile qualities of paper
and studied how light
interacts with the material
to creator our shadows.
We didn't just apply
this approach to our UI.
We actually did
a lot of studies.
We recreated our icons by
folding actual pieces of paper
and placing them in
different lighting set-ups
to understand exactly how those
shadows should be constructed.
These are actual photos that
we studied-- the studies
that we did-- and you can
see all the cool things that
are happening in these photos.
There's soft ambient
shadows caused by the light,
and you can see how the
light is being reflected off
the paper, causing subtle
highlights on the edges.
This process allowed
us understand
how we can
realistically recreate
the subtle highlights and
consistent shadows in a layout.
So, how do we
create the shadows?
There's supposed
to be animation OK.
Imagine this animating.
So, how do we create
these shadows?
In order to make our
shadows feel real,
we needed to create a
technically audacious system
that did more than just
pre-render a static drop
shadow.
So, with our amazing
engineering team,
they built a system that
uses real-time soft shadows.
The shadows are projected from
a virtual light source that
are also being rendered
through a camera.
So, this allowed us to have
consistent set of transforms
that keeps this illusion
alive as the users move
from a screen to
screen, or between apps.
This is the virtual
light source animation
that didn't play earlier, and
there's the virtual camera.
So, these two types
of shadows make up
the shadow layers we
use in material design.
The key shadow creates
the illusion of depth,
while the ambient shadow defines
the form of the material.
Together, the shadows create
a halo around the material
without needing to use a hard
stroke to create an outline.
Aha, animation.
OK.
Shadows also create the
separation between surfaces.
What this means is that the
depth of our shadow changes
scale and focus.
So, elements closer
to the camera
have more diffuse shadows,
and elements further away
from the camera, the shadow
becomes more focused.
So, the strength of
the shadow really
determines the perceived
depth of our material.
You can really see
the differences
between the perceived depth
in these two examples.
The scale of the
shadow helps to show
where these elements
live spatially.
In the example on the left,
the surface of the dialogue
is closer to the
camera, resulting
in a softer shadow, where as
in an example on the right,
cars are further
away from the camera,
resulting in a more
defined shadow.
And, because our
shadows are dynamic,
they also move in
space, depending
on the location of the material
as the camera is fixed.
Like this example, when you
start to see the shadows
move from the left
and right and how
it's moving below
the surface, you
can clearly see how the surface
is being brought to life.
All of these details
might be subtle,
but it really makes up
the whole experience.
The shadows provide
a familiar visual cue
that we just
naturally understand.
So, all of the
theory behind shadows
may sound super complex,
but don't worry.
They're all built
into the system.
Designers can download
an illustrator file
that has the shadows.
And you guys can use them
to design your mocks,
but don't use them
to make assets.
Engineers can simply
set the z-height value
and get system shadows for
Polymer and Android for free.
Now that we've covered
how the shadows are built,
let's look at some examples
of how they are used.
A good way to think
about these surfaces
is that they're tools
to help focus attention
and create emphasis.
So FAB-- a floating
action button--
is a great example of
how we use surfaces
to help focus attention.
Just by virtue of being its
own separate piece of material,
FABS have the most
prominence in our UI,
and this really helps
to promote the action.
A dialogue with
another great example.
Bringing a dialogue to a
surface creates an isolation
of the content, and
allows the users
to focus on things that require
either a decision or action.
Here's a bad example of how
you could overuse shadows
and dimensions in your layout.
Having a surface
on surface in this
is layout distracts from
being able to focus attention.
So, if you see that your design
requires too many layers,
then maybe your
content is too complex.
Shadows should really be used
to determine the surface where
you want your primary
content to be.
Surfaces are powerful grouping
tools for our content.
Like in this cars example,
we can use surfaces
to group complex content
into a digestible view.
This creates a
visual system that
keeps our layout
clean and beautiful
by organizing our
type and imagery,
especially with complex data.
But, we want to
avoid using surfaces
when it's not necessary.
In this list example,
separating each list into cards
adds unnecessary visual
noise, and it also
makes it very difficult to
scan the content quickly.
Surfaces also indicate
interaction cues,
like how things are going to
move and interact in a space.
For example, the peeking
surface in the calculator
is a hint to the user that
they can be pulled out
to reveal something
new or different
from the content they're
currently viewing.
So, we have this
super helpful tool
called the white frames
that you guys can
download from our spec.
They're basic structures
without any content,
so you guys can use
them when you guys are
designing your app.
These layout structures
used a consistent approach
that I mentioned today about
surface layers and shadows.
And we developed these tools
for us designers and developers
to support how we
can better layout
our content in a meaningful way.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTIAN ROBERTSON: So,
we've been talking today
about how bold graphic
design can do more than just
look great.
You've looked at
examples of typography,
and how it helps people to
focus and parse the content.
We've seen how the right
image at the right time
can make all the difference.
We've seen how color
can bring both brand
and also help to divide space,
help people to understand.
We've seen how grids and key
lines can bring structure,
and they're just the coolest.
I'm excited.
[LAUGHTER]
They're like this hidden
super power that you apply it,
and then all of
sudden, everything
just kind of comes into focus,
and things just look amazing.
And finally we've seen how
implied surface can give people
cues about how
they can interact,
but also to help
to divide content.
It's another tool we can
use to structure our apps.
Ultimately, though, the goal
behind this material design
system is to create
a common back story.
This back story can help bring
visual designers, animators,
interaction designers,
engineers together,
and help to create a story
that is consistent for users.
And in some ways, this
is a collaboration
between all of us.
We're creating apps that people
can use based on their shared
understanding of how
the system can work.
They can know how to do things
without thinking about it.
So, to learn more, check
out the information
in the preview release of
the design specifications.
It's not short, so it'll take
a few hours to read through,
but there's a lot of
really good content.
Also, if you're interested in
following our work or reaching
out, you can check
out google.com/design.
And if you've not been able to
catch some of the other design
focus sessions in I/O
you can see them later.
And there's one more session
this afternoon at 4:00
PM to talk about motion design.
The other thing I
wanted to point out
is there's still a
few more hours left.
We have designers
who have been working
on this project
over the past-- I
think it's been over
a year and a half
down in the design sandbox.
Please take advantage of this.
Don't be shy.
We're happy to answer any
questions you might have.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTIAN ROBERTSON: So, it
looks like we're right on time.
We've saved some
time for questions.
If you have
questions, please line
up at either of the microphones
in the center of the aisle.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Any support for SVG
in icons or any kind
of scalable code solution
for all the resolutions
that we currently support?
VIKTOR PERSSON: We
actually have Josh here
who can answer that
question very, very well.
JOSH: Hi.
So, I'm an engineer who works
with all these designers,
and I've been working
on how we manage assets
and how we generate assets.
We're trying to use
SVG more and more.
It's still a bit of a struggle
to use it as the native format
that you're using
within your apps.
Android L is adding
some support for that.
It's getting better
and better on the web,
but there's still
more we need to do.
We are going to be releasing
the system icons that we've
designed as part of the
material on the spec.
So, you'll get those there.
And when we release
them, we'll release
both Ping of various sizes and
densities and also the vector
versions.
So hopefully that will help.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHRISTIAN ROBERTSON:
Thanks, Josh.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
When you said that the grid has
been incorporated conceptually
into the material
design approach,
does that mean you're strongly
recommending that designers
use grids for
layout, or does this
mean that there's new
facilities in the framework
to actually implement
grids at a high level,
and then the elements would
just line themselves upright?
CHRISTIAN ROBERTSON:
So, this is something
that I think starts
with designers.
The tools to align things inside
the platforms to some degree
have existed, and I think it
does start with designers.
VIKTOR PERSSON: Yeah.
And also, all the
numbers are divided
by 8-- so, 8dps increments.
You can see that in everything.
By the size of the buttons
that are provided to you,
or nav drawers, or
app bar heights,
they're all based
on 8dp increments.
CHRISTIAN ROBERTSON: And
all of the basic components
are already using the grids.
AUDIENCE: After
seeing the thinking
behind the lighting
and the camera
and the way shadows move
with the elements on screen,
is there anything in place
to handle orientation
changes so that is more
animated experience,
rather than a broken experience?
CHRISTIAN ROBERTSON: Do we have
some more engineering support
to talk about the
way rotation works?
Yeah.
So there are system
built-in animations
for rotation support.
There's also some facilities to
do custom animations if there's
a particular effect that
you want in your app.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm a UX designer, but
I have a background
in graphic design as well.
So first, I want
to congratulate you
guys on the design
side of things.
It's really good to see some
traditional graphic design
thinking and rules being applied
to the digital environment.
On my UX site, I've noticed
that in terms of affordances,
there's a few instances
where the outlines of buttons
and stuff like that is
slightly trying to fade away.
I want to ask you
guys how do you
feel that apps that have
very defined affordances
will fit with the new material
kind of paradigm design
language that you have designed?
CHRISTIAN ROBERTSON:
Yeah, so I think
that there's two
parts to the question.
One is, what are the right
affordances, and two,
how do we know the right places
to use those affordances?
For example, in
the design system,
there are actual
material buttons
that come off the surface.
And they're a really
great tool for situations
where you have a lot
of complex content.
So, for example, a more complex
form where you need a button.
That's very clear.
We don't necessarily
need it in all places,
like, for example, in the action
bars on top of the screen.
We don't need to have a separate
button around every icon.
So, I think what
I'm trying to say
is, the role of
the designer here
is to look at those
situations and make sure
that there is enough affordance.
And then the system
has a number of steps
you can use when you do need
to have more clarity there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I really liked
the part about color.
And I was wondering-- I
know it's a common thing
to desaturate backgrounds
to reduce eye strain,
and I was wondering about
the really saturated indigo
purple and the magenta.
And when does it become
too much, and how much
do you take of the
really bright colors?
VIKTOR PERSSON: So, thank you.
So, I think what you
really should consider
as a designer is the density
of color and content,
and how those two interact.
Too much color is
not a good thing.
You as a designer have to figure
out where the sweet spot is.
But we believe that we
could incorporate more color
and express your brand
stronger with color
without tiring your user's eyes.
RACHEL BEEN: And we're also
doing accessibility studies
for legibility with
color combinations
as well, with type overlays.
AUDIENCE: So, first, thank you.
It's absolutely
beautiful-- I love
everything you guys are doing.
I had a few questions
about the action bar,
because it's gone over
some real changes.
And I notice that up in
some of the examples,
there's like a darker
yellow, but then we
see a darker icon,
instead of a light icon,
but then with mixed
text where it's white.
Also, I see there's no
icons in the action bar,
and also the hamburger
button's really crazy now.
It's longer integrated.
Just wondering if you could just
give some insights on what's
going on with the
action bar, because it
is a very integral
part of applications,
and unique to Android, really.
CHRISTIAN ROBERTSON: So,
the action bar, I think,
is a whole topic
in and of itself.
There's a few things
that we've started
looking at with the action bar.
As we were looking across
the whole app ecosystem,
there wasn't enough
flexibility for different apps
that had different
needs to really
have the shape of
their app really match
the purpose of the app.
And so this is where
we've done a lot of work
to think about the
relationship between the action
bar and, for example,
a title on the page.
I think there's a
number of screens
that showed a contact, where
it makes a lot more sense
to have the name of
the person really
live inside that same
conceptual block.
So I think that was the
first consideration.
And as it relates to
the branding question of
whether or not we need to have
an app icon up there or a logo,
there's no reason
why we couldn't
have a logo type or a logo
mark up in the action bar.
I think that it probably
makes sense for a lot of apps
to do that, especially
on the top level,
and then you can decide
how much you need it
as you dig in deeper.
AUDIENCE: So it's more
like a content-first type
of thing for the visual.
And the hamburger button?
Anything?
CHRISTIAN ROBERTSON: I mean,
not every screen or every needs
to have a hamburger button.
The ones that do it's in an
appropriate place for it,
and it lines up
with the key lines.
So you really get this-- and
it's true of the titles too--
you get this resonance
with the page.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I just want to say how
all of this design system
has been very inspiring.
And I had a question
about hero images.
Something that I've
seen in the past
is when we've had designs that
are dominated by a bold hero
image.
The problem is, if it's
submitted by the user,
sometimes users don't
pick very good images.
And I wondered if you had any
advice on how you can protect
against bad
user-submitted images?
RACHEL BEEN: Yeah, it's
a really tricky question.
I think one of the things that
we were really considering
is respecting the user's
choices that they're
making to really personalize
their own imagery.
So not manipulating a
user's image, I think,
is a really important
thing to consider.
Because potentially it is
going to appear pixelated,
or it's not necessarily
aesthetically pleasing,
but they're making
that conscious decision
to include it.
It's really tough.
We're doing some affordances to
play with some color overlays
and scrims, but really
it's a fine line
between over-manipulation and
respecting the content, right?
It kind of depends also
on the brand identity
of how you're generally treating
imagery within your product,
as well.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RACHEL BEEN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm an Android developer, and
I really loved your session.
Thanks.
One question I could ask you
is, could you upload an XML file
with all those typographics
scale metrics [INAUDIBLE]
which you want us to use?
So, then you would imply also
naming of all those [INAUDIBLE]
and [INAUDIBLE] sizes?
So it would be consistent across
all teams who develop apps,
so when you move from
one team to another,
it would be consistent.
CHRISTIAN ROBERTSON:
You take that?
VIKTOR PERSSON: Well, no.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRISTIAN ROBERTSON: I think
there's an intersection here
between the design system
and the tools systems.
I'm not sure if we have
anybody from the tools team
that can talk about it.
AUDIENCE: What I
would like is it
you download an XML file, you
drop it into your project,
and you could get all those
the metrics you displayed here
in your projects.
RACHEL BEEN: I don't know if
we've been working on that.
AUDIENCE: Could expect this?
CHRISTIAN ROBERTSON:
I don't know
if I can comment on the
future path of the tools team,
but I think that does
sound like something
that would be useful to make
it easier to use the metrics.
I will say that
the elements that
are built into the framework
do respect these grids,
and you get a certain level
of alignment just there.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I think I've
got a similar question.
I was just wondering if you
were going to build something
into the system overlay--
sorry, the debugger entering
in Android or something, so
that it could show the grid
and so that you could perhaps
make sure elements match up
that way?
It could go in Android's
studio as well.
I don't know if
it's just something
that's been considered?
CHRISTIAN ROBERTSON:
Yeah, I think
that sounds like a good idea.
Again, I can't speak to the
future plans of the tool team.
AUDIENCE: For supporting
older platforms, are you sort
of expecting to go more of
incorporating the new material
elements even on
the order platforms,
much in the way we've backed
ported in action bars,
or to do a more Holo theme
on the older platforms
and only incorporate the
new material elements
on L and above?
CHRISTIAN ROBERTSON:
Yeah, so I think that when
it comes to the
compatibility story--
and again, I think that
this is a whole topic
in and of itself-- you
can kind of break it down
into some different parts.
The first part is for
the layouts themselves
and for those measurements.
For the content itself, the
idea of using this 8 pixel grid
is something that we've actually
been doing since-- the Holo
grids actually use those
measurements as well.
If you lay out your content
with these new things
and use that for
previous versions,
it should work very well.
The things that you
can also-- I don't
know how deep I should
get into talking about all
of the technical features
of the support library--
but the card view element
that's available in the support
library is something
you should look into,
because it will help
you to have shadows
that work across
versions as well.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: It's great to
see such a great design
spec for the first
time in Android.
Considering what the
competition's done,
we all were worried.
But I think I can say it's
been very good to be here
and to see what you
guys have been doing.
It's pretty great.
I have no questions, but
I'll say, keep doing this.
Keep coming up with
design specs we can use.
Not everybody's a designer,
but for developers out there,
it's a very good
guideline to use.
So, keep doing
what you're doing.
Great work.
Thank you very much.
CHRISTIAN ROBERTSON:
Great, thanks.
That was a good wrap-up.
RACHEL BEEN: Yeah, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]